écoute je brûle d'impatience d'entendre
ce que tu vas me raconter comme je
disais ça se passe à notre époque de nos
jours sur terre bon on sait pas vraiment
pourquoi mais subitement les postes de
télévision deviennent très méchant
partout sur terre ouais t'es refléter
les envoie des ondes très puissante qui
font cramer les gens de l'intérieur
ah c'est bien ça j'adore les gens
souffrent il souffrit sofres autres à
fond je veux que ce soit le meilleur
gémissements de l'histoire du cinéma
et si l'objet miss monde convient alors
aussi et tu fais ton fils je veux un
oscar pour ce gémissements gémissements
numéro 45
je suis en train de perdre les pédales
y'a quoi sur cette [ __ ] de cassette on
aimerait savoir qui milite en plein
travaux ninja certains comme moi je vais
à l'oscar pour ses gémissements jason tu
m'entends
jason centre qu'est ce que tu dit ça je
ne peux pas te fais je peux pas me lever
je suis collé au siège
je crois que brics enregistré des heures
comme ça comme un con et kubrick mes
couilles